I wanted to mention to that of course in
the world of politics it feels like this
elections been going on forever but
things are finally starting we're
something meaningful heck yes the Iowa
caucuses are exactly two months away and
one second hello what I really have the
power to force Mexico to build a wall of
course that it's absurd I think Donald
Trump he must have butt-dialed me what
I'm selling is a twisted fantasy that a
lot of sickos frankly buy again to mr.
Tom can you hear me mr. Chuck what what
the hell they're like that it's tonin
O'Brien sir I think you butt-dialed me
Kate it's good sorry about that Godin
okay what were you saying about the wall
the wall yeah you sing the one you never
to build it it's good to keep out the
killers in the rapist the beste kids
will pay for Edie they're gonna thank me
for it
wait they're gonna thank you for it as
well look coded I'd love to stay and
chat but I'd better get paid to read say
it okay anyway that's crazy
but to help me out of that whoa that's
weird all right anyway the Iowa caucuses
we're celebrating a lot of people are
going to believe me you know these
morons eat this stuff up that's why I
say sir sir
like this it's total O'Brien again
goaded why do you keep calling me I
didn't call you sir your butt dialing me
now were you saying you didn't see
Muslims in New Jersey celebrating I
think you just said that I see them
saying that God's sacrifice either go to
wait a minute sir no one was sacrificing
goats selected I saw what it happened I
know goats I gotta go
particulate I'm sorry about that anyway
the Iowa caucuses are just a my god yes
hello
what elected I'm going to sell the White
House to China and then turn the Lincoln
Memorial into a full relief spa
mr. Trump you butt-dialed me again no I
did I got to tell you about my plan to
turn the Lincoln Memorial into a full
relief spa and he's already an
investor who doesn't like full release
Oh God wasn't that a great clip
subscribe to my youtube channel for an
endless supply of me
[Laughter]